Apple just shocked the World by
announcing the M3 M3 Pro and M3 Max
chips all at the same time in a suite of
brand new 14 and 16-in MacBook Pros and
yes they finally ditched that outdated
13-in MacBook Pro Design and gave us
something that's actually much better
than I expected which I'll explain in
just a minute but all of this makes it
much more difficult to choose the right
new Macbook Pro in late 2023 espe
especially with the downgraded M3 Pro
chip so in this video I'm going to lay
out precisely everything that's new and
I promise you're going to know exactly
which model to buy by the end of this
video so let's jump right into it first
of all the general design of the 14 and
16-in MacBook Pro hasn't changed one bit
except that you can now finally get the
14-in design with the consumer M3 chip
at only
$1,600 instead of having pay $2,000 like
we did previously and for both of the
high-end models we finally have a space
black finish that officially replaces
the space gray using a brand new
anodization process that's meant to stop
fingerprints and this color alone is
really tempting me into upgrading even
though I know I don't need to now as far
as the features everything's basically
the same except for the fact that Apple
slightly bumped up the standard
brightness of the displays to 600 nits
compared to 500 so it's going to be a
bit brighter for regular use including
web browsing but the maximum brightness
isn't changing at all and to my surprise
or literal shock the base 14-in model
comes with the same liquid Retina xdr
Display including the same 600 nits of
brightness and the same 120 HZ promotion
technology I legitimately expected Apple
to tone those features down for the base
model but they did didn't huge Bravo
it's also got the same 1080p webcam the
same six- speaker sound system the
studio quality mics and Wi-Fi 6E in
Bluetooth 5.3 specs in fact I only found
four major differences with one of them
being the loss of the Thunderbolt 4
ports that the high-end 14-in model has
which makes sense for the second
difference the Bas M3 model still has
the limitation of only supporting One
external display compared to two on the
M3 Pro and four four on the M3 Max even
though the M3 has the HDMI port and two
Thunderbolt 4 ports it's still only
supports One external display for number
three it only has a single fan for
cooling because honestly that's all the
regular M3 chip really needs and for the
fourth difference the bass M3 14-in
MacBook Pro has a slightly smaller
battery at 70 W hours instead of
72.4 but because of the low power usage
M3 chip it it actually gets better
battery life at 15 hours of wireless web
compared to 12 on the M3 pro version of
the 14-in and 22 hours of Apple TV app
movie Playback instead of 18 basically
matching the battery life of the 16-in
MacBook Pro now as for the 14in 16-in
high-end MacBook Pros everything has
stayed the same feature-wise other than
what I've already mentioned except that
Apple also talked about a new Advanced
thermal architect
so the cooling should hopefully be a lot
better and now before we get into
explaining which one you should buy I've
got to talk about the chip differences
and Apple's sneaky pricing changes this
year the M3 chip has the same 8 core
layout as the M2 using four performance
cores and four efficiency cores for the
CPU as well as 10 GPU cores and to my
surprise it gets all of the new GPU
features including the new mesh Shader
architecture Ray tracing and the brand
new Dynamic caching feature the M3 model
also comes with a 512 GB SSD standard
which means that you finally get two
nand flash chips which will finally
solve the huge single Nan chip
performance issues that we had last year
on the base M2 Max now moving on to the
M3 Pro chip this one is really weird
because it actually got downgraded in
more ways than one compared to the
previous M2 Pro first of all the M3 pro
has 37 billion transistors a downgrade
from 40 billion on the M2 Pro this
likely helps Apple save costs and
improve yields on the expensive 3
nanometer Wafers from tsmc so that they
can keep the price at the same
$19.99 however in order to do that they
actually had to also downgrade the core
layout yes it still has up to 12 CPU
cores but they they took away two of the
very important performance cores and
swapped them out for another two ecores
so instead of getting eight performance
cores and four efficiency like we had on
the M2 Pro we now only get six
performance and we get six efficiency on
Apple's M3 Pro chip slide they mentioned
the M3 Pro is 20% faster than the first
generation M1 Pro chip the M2 Pro was
already 20% faster than the m one pro so
there's basically no improvement making
it even worse the bass M3 Pro now comes
with a 14 core Bend GPU compared to 16
on the previous M2 so they took away two
GPU cores and then when you pay to
upgrade to the fully unbin ship you only
get 18 GPU cores compared to the
previous 19 cores another downgrade but
wait it actually gets worse because the
M3 pro has less memory bandwidth
compared to the M2 Pro only 150 GB per
second compared to the previous 200 GB
per second this is because they have
apparently switched to using a setup of
three memory modules on the M3 Pro
compared to four modules on the previous
M2 Pro but at least that meant that we
got a silent upgrade to 18 GB of RAM in
the form of Three 6 GB memory modules
instead of the previous 16 gigs of RAM
those are all very weird choices but my
only guess is that Apple realized that
they previously made the mistake in
making the pro chip so close in
performance to the max chip and now
they're downgrading it to make the max
look even better and now with that said
we finally have the new M3 Max chip
where Apple absolutely pulled out all of
the stops and made it better than I
expected instead of getting downgraded
Apple has actually given it a m massive
16 cor CPU with the same four efficiency
cores but up to 12 performance cores
which is absolutely bonkers the only
downside is that unlike last year where
you got the full 12 core CPU on any M3
Max model the base model doesn't get the
full 16 core CPU it instead gets a Bend
14 core CPU and actually the same Bend
30 core GPU as on the m to Max but for
$300 more you can upgrade it to the
fully unbend 16 core CPU and 14 core GPU
right well no because you're actually
forced into upgrading to 48 gigs of RAM
if you want the best M3 Max ship so
that's a huge instant $500 upgrade but
the nice thing is that if you're not
planning on that upgrade they're now
giving the base model 36 gigs of RAM
instead of 32 which is a nice little
bonus but now with all that said let me
get into the buyer guide portion of this
video let's start with the new base M3
14-in MacBook Pro which I believe is an
absolutely killer value for
$1600 it comes with the new 14-in
redesign with those nice curved edges
the additional HDMI port the SD card
slot Max safe 3 for charging and the
mini LED display with no downgrades
compared to the high-end models which
blew my mind and making it even better
it's only $100 more than the old
outdated M2 MacBook Pro when you factor
in the fact that it has an upgraded 512
gig SSD at the base price so in my
opinion if you don't need the
performance of the M3 Pro or Max which I
would argue 80% of people don't then
seriously just buy the M3 14-inch
MacBook Pro model and you're going to be
happy now moving on to the 14in M3 pro
model this is the one that really
disappointed me with all of those chip
downgrades and for this one you should
honestly only buy it over the regular M3
model for three reasons number one is if
you really want that new space black
finish number two is if you really want
more performance seeing as the M3 Pro
gets 11 CPU cores instead of eight and
14 GPU cores instead of 10 at the base
price with available upgrades and number
three is if 8 gigs of RAM isn't enough
for you on the base M3 model and you
were going to upgrade to 16 gigs which
brings the price up to
$1,800 making it cost only $200 less
than the M3 pro version which actually
gets 18 gigs of RAM and a lot of the
performance improvements as well as the
additional fan Thunderbolt port and
support for another external display but
if none of those things matter that much
to you then seriously just get the M3
14-in MacBook Pro model now the only
other reason to get the M3 Pro chip is
if you really want the 16-in MacBook Pro
size which comes base with the unbinned
12 core M3 Pro chip for
$2500 but let me tell you the M3 Max is
truly the one that you want to buy this
year if you care about value and
performance and if you could afford it
regardless of whether it's in the 14in
or 16-in size it just got such a huge
upgrade to the CPU and GPU that it's
actually worth the upgrade especially
the fully loaded 16 core CPU model
however the only issue with the base M3
Max chip model is that it now comes Bend
with only 14 CPU cores so only in extra
two performance cores compared to last
year's M2 Max so if you want the full M3
Max you've got to pay that $500 upgrade
which gets very expensive so my advice
is that this is only for those who want
to go all out and get the absolute most
performance in a laptop this is for
people who have complex CPU workloads or
tasks that actually make them money in
terms of their small business work or
whatever else especially if you can get
a business right off for it it's also
for those who want the absolute best
graphics performance for things like
blender rendering or gaming especially
thanks to rate tracing and the other GPU
improvements but honestly I'd like to
mention again that the regular M3 chip
is more than good enough for most people
out there doing common work so don't
spend your money if you don't have to
especially in this economy so with that
said hopefully you enjoy this buyer
guide and if you have any further
questions or you need purchasing advice
let me know down in the comment section
below and if you're struggling with the
question of if you should upgrade or not
check out that video over there and
subscribe for our in-depth testing
videos next week thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video